mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
der inhalt der folgenden sendung ist für
kinder und jugendliche unter 16 jahren
nicht gerechnet daher wird das logo
durch einen roten balken ergänzt
kruse und grauen lauern überall
die unterhaltungsbranche setzt auf den
kalkulierten schrecken
so dass ich irgendwie
einfach immer
faszinierend sehr
horror filme und serien sind grad wieder
groß im trend warum diese lust und angst
die eigene angst und betreut gefühlt
genießen
hier kommt niemand so leicht davon
[Musik]
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz ja ein
einkaufszentrum in rom nahm hier
erwarten wir erst mal keine große
aufregung aber genau dafür sind wir
heute hier ich will nämlich in einen
escape ruhm und dort wird gruseln und
nervenkitzel so richtig zelebriert
[Musik]
mission escape hier will ich
herausfinden weshalb die lust an der
angst momentan hochkonjunktur feiert
[Musik]
ja das horrorgenre feiert ein hoch wie
noch nie im film auf streaming
plattformen und zunehmend auch mit live
bands
was steckt denn dahinter dass wir gerade
in zeiten wie diesen so sehr abfahrt auf
die lust am grusel geistern und gemetzel
[Musik]
horror lebt obwohl es dabei zumeist ums
sterben geht
[Applaus]
der plattform vom horror schocker mit
hollywood stars in horb als fieser
kindermörder existiert bislang nur der
film
im film wird ein schuljunge entführt und
in einem verlies mit einem alten telefon
gefangen gehalten
das zitiert
noch vor kinostart wird der plattform
von der horrorfilm community als
höhepunkt des kinojahres gefeiert
bereits zwei wochen im kino skript 5
die kultreihe exemplarisch für die
wirkung von horror ist einfach die
eigene angst und bedrohliches gefühl
genießen
[Musik]
[ __ ] you tube
erstmals möchte ghostface 1996
ahnungslose teenager
drei fortsetzungen folgten bis 2011 dann
war pause
[Musik]
nun ist ghostface zurück und hat kurz
nach kinostart das fünffache des
produktionsbudgets eingespielt
medienprofessorin christine lötscher
hier treffen sie auf dem friedhof ein
gängiger schauplatz für horrorfilme
die lust an der angst hat sie selbst im
blut ich persönlich bin bin ich
fasziniert euro fehlen das hat
wahrscheinlich die mixtur dass ich als
kind ihren augen straße 47 und
horrorfilme extrem beruhigend machen
auch erst sehr gut schlafen
gewissermaßen als konfrontationstherapie
gegen eigene ängste in zeiten voller
unsicherheiten anscheinend besonders
gefragt
die netflix serie helm und lag
zwischenzeitlich weltweit auf platz 1
der streaming shorts
übernatürliche kreaturen befördern ihre
opfer in die hölle und begründen einen
sekt im kult
können blutrünstige monster tatsächlich
unsere inneren spannungen abbauen
eine etwas platte interpretation auf den
ersten blick
tatsächlich so die expertin finde sich
die aussagekraft von horror produktionen
auf der metaebene oktober film also sie
stellt alles was dieses mal darf
selbstverständlich in frage also grenze
zwischen leben und da muss man schon die
ganze vorgeschichte
thematisiert sexualität und gewalt also
selbst die grenze lösen das gruseln
daheim natürlich wahnsinnig das ist dass
man so ein horror so spannend macht die
akzeptanz des horrorgenres hat
jahrzehnte gebraucht mit dem video boom
anfang der 80er jahre kam der horror
plötzlich ins wohn und schlimmer ins
kinderzimmer
anlass für eine kritische befassung im
öffentlichen fernsehen die produkte um
die es jetzt hier geht sind in jedem
video laden erhältlich trotzdem werden
viele von ihnen liebe zuschauer solche
scheußlichkeiten noch nie gesehen haben
[Musik]
filme wie diesen müssen mitarbeiter der
bundesprüfstelle für jugendgefährdende
schriften täglich begutachten
[Musik]
und
mainstream kino und fernseh für allemal
wie die regisseure und regisseurinnen wo
das wegmachen
damals jung sie sind und die horror film
halt gelebt hat und so geht's praktisch
jedem krimi jeder teenie serie gibt es
aber relevant
auch wenn nicht horror drauf steht wie
in der sf serie wilder ist horror drin
in dieser produktion wird gar die
unschuld vom lande
[Musik]
zum blutrünstigen mert heidi schweizer
heimat film als blatter spektakel
filmstart im herbst
kino riffraff zürich
hier gibt's vor als film marathon
in kooperation mit dem verein never walk
alone zu deutsch schau niemals allein
also dass ich die idee wo eigentlich zu
amerika schon längst etabliert ist und
sieht 50 otto quentin tarantino will die
sind immer immer zwölf stunden lang
horrorfilm zeigen hier eingefunden das
muss unbedingt dreitürige sammle uhr
horrorfilm einfach nochmal viel mehr
spaß macht dass ich das kann sich der
schräg chinesische star über schlachten
film oder gurt die film und in eine
extreme emotionen vom horror film gottes
verständigt
die eventisierung des grauens
greift weiter um sich
horror parks gehören in den usa oder in
deutschland zu halloween wie das wiener
lied zum kürbis suppe
auch hier sie die schweiz nach in den
leer stehenden hallen der ehemaligen
matschie fabrik bei winterthur entsteht
eine schaurig schreckliche erlebnis welt
dahinter steckt
der groß veranstalter good news
das geht mit befinden premiere bei
scream an der spitze gibt es gibt ganz
viel wie er nachts märz ganz viele
halloween kürbis wunder helfen und so
was hat man nicht wähle einander
eventuell wird mit verschreckt hat nach
amerikanischen modell und treiben die
richtig schaffen der horror park wird ab
16 jahren zugänglich sein
das haben wir mit content mit statisten
mit monster mit ton mit rauch mit licht
mit schmuck renovierten
niederschlagung definitiv
ein weiterer grund für den aktuellen
horror boom sozial und
gesellschaftskritik thematisiert genre
zunehmend offen
in der horror satire get out wird sich
die hauptfigur gegen seine weißen
peiniger ein kommentar auf den
strukturellen rassismus in den usa
häufig ist hochpolitisch es geht
antirassistische hörisch
grundsätzlich immer sellschaft kritisch
da ich der kanten ist gewachsen dass das
eigentlich das wichtigste ist das
wertvollste stück geht out kommt aus dem
produktionshaus von jason blum der sich
dem gesellschaftskritischen horror
verschrieben hat und sich öffentlich
gegen die tram präsidentschaft stellt
auch der plattform ist von blauen haus
mit produziert der kinostart wurde von
januar auf den sommer verschoben
die horror film community wird noch
etwas länger auf die folter gespannt
[Musik]
ich erwarte dass sabrina die
mitinhaberin von mission escape ich
meine ich wirklich ne ganz freiwillig
dahin was erwartet mich würde sage ganz
viel action und viel spaß dass auf jeden
fall konnte ja kleines
mädchen hoffen hier ja es keinen
wirklich zurück ich bin auf reede
schießhaus wie man es dann so salbe so
live macht ich es schon als vierte frau
ist sehr viel einfacher kriftel am
schluss haben wir
sind voll im trend mit dem thema süd
handel stufte mcchrystal hat die freude
oder angst erlaube die das also auf
jeden fall während als gefühl dass es so
gehört das nachfrage da ist
primär ein spieler was ist eigentlich
ein essay ruhm wenn man dann so richtig
macht ausgerechnet fußball nie was er
wollte sein es ist eine gruppe zwei und
sechs personen und ja münster zwar die
sperre herum und man hat nach acht
minuten zieht zum video the finder und
auf ihrem weg als bereichen gut
kombinieren das gesprungen dass man das
im team macht es mir das eben nicht
allein löst sondern dass ich habe großen
spaß faktor natürlich brauche dass man
das team dann geschafft
[Musik]
o
der horror hat ja beste tradition wir
alle kennen graf dracula und dann kam
der film und gab dem grauen ein gesicht
wir machen jetzt eine kleine reise in
die schrecklichen abgründe der
filmgeschichte
[Musik]
das personifizierte grauen geisterte
bereits vor 100 jahren über die leinwand
losfee radtour des dumpfen von 1922 mit
bildern für die ewigkeit die erste film
adaption des literaturklassikers dracula
schuf eine bildsprache die bis heute
gültigkeit hat
mit dem farbfilm kann das blut in die
kinos
und genau solche szene zu verhindern
hatte hollywood den sogenannten spot
entwickelt der brutale oder
sexualisierte filmszenen auf den index
setzte
[Musik]
dort fließt erfüllte alles was dem
damals gültigen zensur tod diametral
widersprach so esse hre filmexperte
lorenz
er gilt ja hinlänglich als der erste
film also jene art von horrorfilmen wo
es darum geht viel blut zu zeigen und wo
körperteile abgehakt werden das sind
jetzt diesem film unter anderem ein bein
und eine zunge er steht aber auch dafür
dass der hays code der produktion school
langsam an wirkung verloren vier jahre
nach dem film wurde auch der produktions
code dann endgültig abgeschafft und es
war wieder alles möglich irgendwie mann
und frauen ein bett drogenmissbrauch
unterhalt gewalt
ein allzeit klassiker das zombie genre
bis heute nicht totzukriegen
mai trifft in living dead setzte hier
neue maßstäbe
george romeros klassiker unterlegte den
grusel mit scharfsinniger sozialkritik
was erst jahrzehnte später anerkannt
wurde das ist einer dieser filme die
irgendwie laufe der jahrzehnte an
bedeutung gewonnen haben er hat ja
letztendlich das zombie genre was bis
heute bund irgendwie gegründet er hat
den horror aus verschlossenen
transsilvanien vor unserer haustür
geholt und heute gilt ja auch als
allegorie für rassismus weil ja der
afro-amerikanische hält zwar alle zombie
angriffe über steht aber am ende von
weißen rednecks erschossen wird der film
ist inzwischen teil des us national film
registry dem nationalen verzeichnis mit
besonders erhaltenswerten filmen
[Musik]
es gibt wenige viel mit ihren titel
selbst jene kennen die nie gesehen haben
der exorzist ist einer davon
[Applaus]
ja so ein horrorfilm hat man ein bis 92
73 nicht gesehen im kern ein psychodrama
mit guten schauspieler langsam erzählt
alles sehr realistisch obwohl das ganze
ja was fantastisch ist erzählt von einer
zwölfjährigen die mit von einem dämon
besessen ist und dann hat man dieses
psychodrama ja mit 10 unterschritten die
die man vorher so und der form nicht
gesehen hat
damals war das ja sogar so dass die
leute im kino ohnmächtig geworden sind
oder sich sogar übergeben haben die
krude teufelsaustreibung schafft er es
zu höchsten film gehen zwei oscars für
das beste drehbuch und den besten tun
aktuelle horror filme und serien
verknüpfen die sub genres zunimmt in der
filmreihe the bridge ist die
sozialkritik offensichtlich eliten
lassen sozial schwächere in der
kampfarena gegeneinander antreten psycho
horror trifft / a movie
der horrorfilm ist in die jahre gekommen
aber
seine geschichte ist längst nicht zu
ende erzählt
[Musik]
yahoo und nervenkitzel das gibt es auch
aus kopfkino nämlich dann wenn mir
jemand eine gruselige geschichte erzählt
ich erinnere mich an den wohligen
schauer mit franz hohler story auf
kassette am liebsten nachts im zelt ja
und das schreckt viele haben radio das
gibt es auch bereits seit generationen
dabei setzt simon krautloher kollegin
ihr führer quasi die tradition wieder
mit dem schrecken produzieren den
podcast frauen heißt für wen machen die
das wirklich so schrecklich ansage des
grauen jüngerem zuhörerinnen und zuhörer
gemacht ist wir sind selber große fan
von großen kino und lernt ihr also pro
film einfließen
und die sind ja ganz genau sieht
halloween 20 unterwegs mit dem podcast
lassen wir doch geht es ihnen wie das da
so das ist folgt 3
ich hab doch gesagt ich hab sie nicht
angerufen
was ich das gesicht im gleichen moment
wird frau vom notruf
[Musik]
ich bin
ist größer wird es wirklich spannend und
es ist ja so war man ein podcast los
dann hat man es ja meistens mit
kopfhörer es ist sehr nah ist das der
unterschied eigentlich zum ludwigsfeld
doch ob es entscheidend das bild hat
zwar kasper vor gesetz beruht aber das
war schon beschrieben hat mit pokal
sowie kopfhörer lustig eigentlich geht
es stufe oder radio oder walkend wie im
eigenen kopf gehen und das macht seine
faxen körperliche erfahrung findet es
gibt acryl schwierig erweisen oder
sprachen auch noch
welche körperliche fähigkeiten es los
und ich glaube dass ich natürlich schon
einmal intensiver als im film es geht ja
studio wo seit mit größerer mit
horrorfilm oder mit zu hoher alice
cooper bester durch pantomimische
unterschrieben ja die pandemie oder
einfach zu langsam aber ich denke ich
schon ins ventil als und angst dass ich
vielleicht eher diffus sind dann
wirklich materialisiert du jetzt aber
ist das ist ja immer schön im sicheren
raum es kann alles passieren
geht's ganz froh jetzt auch brutalität
der bergrettung museums sind die eigenen
bilder wo man da quasi
ist laufen bringt viele zuhörer wieder
zu hören ja man hat ja recht breites
spektrum aber auch themen behandelt die
den erfolg und gibt schon so ticken
expliziter sind also mir hat mal ein
förster mit einer kettensäge oder ein
riss durch die sache damit macht aber
häufig ist der horror asyl und eher
sachlich theologisch reaktionen zeigen
dass
brüssel oder der horror ja
unterschiedliche orte empfehlen dass es
nicht für alle gleich ist wirklich bis
auf knochen machen
danke für das gespräch sie lernt jetzt
gerade eine stimme kann nämlich vor der
schauspielerin vera bondar und mit ihrer
der frage nach woher eigentlich heiße
luft und angst und
ich bin trainer bomben schauspielerin
und ich spreche im podcast grauert rolle
von steffi immer vollmond
[Musik]
ja wie ein grusel podcast grauen gott um
vier freunde immer vollmond am lager für
treffen heute
nati begrüßen ist langsam zum gruße
verwendet werden und das ergeht sich
immer das per gratis gruselig erlebte
gesicht der nachtzug volk ist ein
relativ simple steffi
erzählt wie sie früher auf interesse und
wo grad trickov zufahrt und
auf der zugfahrt hatte ein zwei
begegnungen der besonderen art
weil ich oft wach bis mitternacht
gesehen
und dazu gestanden
für die zugtüren aufgegangen sind so
ganz stimmt
aber gruselgeschichte fasziniert mich
einfach gerannt so
realität und fiktion
also könnte mir jetzt wirklich passieren
und ich steigere mich drinnen und
empfinde ein reizte mich trainiert
steigere und bin dann doch immer wieder
mal froh dass es nicht so ist also immer
das spiel hier und her aus frau gar
nicht wieso ich finde ich das so
reizvoll
wo ich anfangen lassen also nicht dann
so richtig viel klasse haben mit zwölf
habe ich nur krimis und psycho thrillers
klasse und das fällt mir erst jetzt und
ich viel anders ließe einfach wieder
als teenie horror film so das ist
irgendwie
einfach immer
faszinierend sie
ich bin eine ganz kleine dorf leben
tessin aufgewachsen und ganze dorf
besteht aus stein und ausblicke und ist
ganz ganz kleine gasse und wir sind
hinter gesicht der durchwachsen bin und
es gibt unzählige geschichten ihre seite
wieder viele steinterrasse artikel
friedhof und im hauptprogramm
der friedhof touren so ganz aber und
wieder offen
die angstlust ja ja lust über die
eigenen grenzen und
sorge was was ich dafür ein abgrund und
leute wie groß der schritt den abgang
machen aber ganz so das ist bei noch
zurückziehen
[Musik]
eine rolle
da
[Musik]
das war unser ausflug in die welt des
horrors und ich bin mit dem schrecken
davon gekommen nächste woche geht es bei
uns um geschlechter diversität und wie
wir damit umgehen und gleich im
anschluss auf sf1 wird darüber auch in
der sternstunde philosophie debattiert
kommen sie gut durch die woche ist
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen ihr kultur
tourismus
[Musik]